at the department of operations research
and financial engineering so it's a
unique name but we do optimization there
okay so so I'm gonna talk about how can
we possibly solve Markov decision
problems faster using randomized
iterative hours ins and also I'm hoping
to make a connection with reinforcement
learning okay so this is the all-out my
talk so I'm going to start with a brief
introduction to Markov decision process
all the terminologies and patience and
now won't you give you an example of how
to use basic stochastic first-order
masters to solve Markov decision process
by formulating a problem into a specific
set of point formulation and that
particular set opala formulation is very
nice in a way that we actually have a PI
D in your Lagrangian function and we can
use samples in the most efficient way to
figure out the optimal policy and this
has a natural extension to reinforce um
learning and we can actually make a
strong connection between runtime
complexity for solving the computation
problem and sample complexity for
learning the optimal policy and I'm also
going to show you some recent works on
conversational compactly lower bound for
solving MVP and some other related works
on latter equations okay so I'm going to
jump into the technical formulation okay
so I would assume everyone knows miraka
same problems so MVP is the most
fundamental framework in stochastic
control and reinforcement learning it
models a Markov chain which can be
controlled by us so basically we have
some discrete finite discrete state
space on which we have a random walk and
at each state we can observe that state
and apply some action so we can
decide how to control the random walk in
order to make ourselves happy so if we
look at most of this AI applications I
mean games like Tetris were poker if we
assume that I'm playing with a
stationary opponent or go if I assume
that I'm playing with again a stationary
opponent not an adapter one okay so as
long as we're trying to make decisions
make sequential decisions in a dynamic
process in order to maximize some
objective then we fall into the regime
of Markov decision process okay so two
is quite a Markov decision problem so we
need to specify the transition
probabilities from States to States
under possible actions so we're going to
work with a finite state space s and at
each state we're going to be looking at
a set of actions a so we are going to
look at the same action set for each
state so now in order to specify the
transition probabilities we're actually
looking at a tensor which is a state by
action by state tensor and the
dimensionality is s squared times a okay
and also so it's a that we move from
certain state I to J according to some
action and we generate some reward so
the reward is going to be again a
function of state action and the future
state and for simplicity and I say that
all words are bounded between 0 and 1 ok
so if you give me all those values those
p values and there are values then the
problem is fully specified we should be
able to solve it now what is our
objective objective and appearance
basically I want to control my random
work on the state space in a way so that
maximize the cumulative which hurt and
certain state transition is going to
generate a score right for example in
Tetris ones will eliminate some line we
are going to make one point and if I
don't do anything we are going to make
zero point and then we want to maximize
expectation of
total scores generated by this process
okay so mathematically speaking the
objective is here so here I'm using a
mixed objective so I can accommodate
post discounted case was undiscounted
case but in the discount in the
discounted case essentially we're going
to add a discount factor to penalize
future rewards in order to make sure
that our problem is contracted in a nice
way and in the more general case without
discount factor so gamma would equal to
1 that would correspond to a gate to the
case in which I actually want to control
this process forever and I want to make
sure that the average score I get per
each transition is maximized so
essentially if we take gamma equals to 1
then this objective converges to the
objective of undiscounted every average
we were MVP but sometimes to make things
to make life easier we just take a
discount factor gamma to be students
more than one to not to get contraction
okay so this is the MVP problem okay so
I'm going to focus on the computation
complexity of the problem meaning that
I'm going to assume that I'm given all
this model specifications I know all the
transition probabilities other words and
I just want to compute the optimal
policy or to approximate it and I care
about runtime complexity okay
so again so some background so whenever
we talk about Markov design process we
need to define value functions so we
let's do it again here so we can define
the value vector for finite states or
value function for infinite states okay
so beta P the value is going to be the
total cumulative return we can generate
from this infinite process starting from
given state I
the total value definitely depends on
the initial state so we have a function
of values each quiz bounced to one
particular state and we have visited a
value vector for each stationary policy
pi and the automatic condition of MVP is
the well-known well-known bellman
equation which is the equation for the
optimal value vector so physically
bellman equation businesses that we have
to be doing optimally at every time step
taking into consideration all the
infinite future
so this video says that starting at
state I I want to choose some action a
to maximize the sum of my immediate
reward and future reward starting at the
next time step and in the discount case
we have a discount factor R gamma okay
so in specially solving MDP both down to
solving the system of nonlinear
equations so they are equivalent okay
and also if we just try to figure out
the corresponding best a for each state
I we get an optimal policy which is
going to be an automatic policy so
that's the background so if you look at
a major approaches in Markov decision
problems or even more generate than I'm
a programming okay so I think the first
two major approaches are going to be
valuation Attalla situation they dated
back to like 1950s and then sure not
long after the development of bellman
equation people soon realized that
Parana equations are equivalent to
linear programs so we can also use
linear programming method to solve it so
if we just look at all the deterministic
algorithms or even randomized algorithms
including the best algorithm for LP to
solve
Belma equations then we get all those
random complex
so here we are measuring the runtime in
terms of number of arithmetic operations
okay and even look at those four
complexities we notice that all of them
are at least linear most of the action
is super linear so linear or super
linear with respect to the input size so
what is input size we call that input
sizes I square a okay and however so if
we look into the literature of
reinforcement learning like one of the
most popular hours on is Q learning and
if we try to understand what skew
learning is doing coolin is essentially
a randomized version of valuation and by
using huling is possible to get a better
sample complexity but it's not clear how
well how can we push this into a faster
runtime complexity so when I did a
question around to ask us can we trade
the precision of the exam policy for a
better run huh say that a Mojave was a
90 percent optimal policy maybe 80% and
that's good enough and I would be happy
with such a approximate policy and I
really want my runtime to be way smaller
than those super linear time complexity
okay so this is the motivation so the
answer is yes otherwise I wouldn't raise
that question okay so now
then he says let's look at the linear
program formulations of bellman equation
anyway so essentially if we take a
closer look into the literature about
MVP and Velma equations we clearly
realize that they are basically linear
programs so the poem the primal
formulation for the bellman equation is
in the value vector R exactly I want to
find value vectors to satisfy my bellman
equation and by satisfying about my
equation meaning that I want I want some
of those inequalities to be thorough
okay and similarly we can also derive
the dual problem so the dual problem has
a very nice physical interpretation so
the dual problem is also very natural in
our study MDP so we call that
yeah I'm DP our objective is to find a
policy in order to maximize the real
world let's consider every range and so
my goal is simply that I want to
maximize the average reward so it's a
singular value determined by PI and I
want to find such a path so this is my
objective right so we can derive the two
formulation very easily by checking the
stationary distribution corresponding to
a policy path so I'm going to let sci-fi
to be stationary distribution under
policies high stationary distribution of
states under policy paths and I'm going
to call our PI s to be
single
state-transition tradition reward okay
so if we read it right in this way it's
actually my addiction problem becomes
does I want to find the stationary
distribution over States together with
one step through work function to
maximize their inner product right
and I can free up
why cuz I as a function of Pi by
optimizing joint in the Oh world cuz I
and the pie with a additional assumption
that because I transpose in close to
because I transpose
okay so if we keep playing this game and
eventually I'm going to define my dual
variable us Joint Distribution of
probability on the space of state and
action pair
mu of as an a is the probability for us
to up to occur and also the protective
probability for me to choose action a
conditional state asks so after we do
this transformation we notice that odors
cosine hi they disappear and this entire
program becomes a linear program in mu
so this is the crisp omnia linear
program in the discount given twirled
case okay so essentially we could be
looking for the best value vector to
match the bellman equation or we could
be looking for the best stationary
distribution in order to maximize
migrant work and those two problems
happen to be dual to each other and we
have a strong duality between optimal
value and optimal policy together with
the optimal organic distribution over
States okay so if we just use linear
duality we can easily realize that okay
now you order to solve the primal
problem physically I want to find those
constraints that are active at optimal
solution and in the 213 it means that I
want to find certain coordinates of my
two variable that achieve their own so
essentially I'm trying to find the basis
of my dual solution so finding the
optimal policy is equivalent to finding
the basis of the basic of extreme point
solution in linear programming okay so
that's enough for the background so now
I'm going to develop the algorithm so
apparently I mean I want to solve the
linear formulations of bellman equation
but I'm going to focus on the
undiscounted case for now for simplicity
but because I discard the discount
factor so I lose nice boundedness and
contraction yes so I'm going to make
additional assumptions on the stochastic
process so that I'm working with a
reasonable reasonable class of problems
so I'm going to make two assumptions the
first assumption is going to say that
I'm going to look at problems in which
older policies are going to generate
somewhat similar
stationary distributions
so basically I want the station and
distributions
according to under some policy of height
should be varying within certain range
so they cannot be too far away from each
other
so this basically requires that my
policies should be relatively similar
and sufficiently our Gothic and second
condition is I want my mark of the same
process to be rapidly mixing so I'm
going to assume that I know a union from
upper bound on the mixing time of the
Markov chain under all stationary
policies alternative way to understand
this may be my original problem does not
satisfy those conditions but I'm going
to focus on policies that are within
such range and I'm going to be looking
for the best policy from that range okay
so now let's continue with our linear
programming formulation so we go down
the primal into so naturally we can
write down the min max formulation using
Lagrangian duality and this is the
lagrangian function the case 1 there's
no discomfort or gamma equals 1 so some
terms cancel off which I like ok so this
is a very nice objective function
essentially a spidey near emu my du
variable and also linear in V which is
my primal variable the value vector ok
so the reason for me to make those
assumptions
I want to bound the complexity for
search spaces of this problem so I'm
going to construct a search set for the
value function and a search set for the
dual variable which satisfy bution over
all policies and it's corresponding on a
stationary distribution so basically if
I know that my problem is we have been
mixing then I should be able to know
that my value function is bounded in our
Infinity ball with radius 2 times the
mixing haim and similarly I also know
that my do variable is going to be a
distribution over state action pairs so
it has belongs to a simplex and if I
have addition or guarding assumptions I
can put here my prior knowledge here
so basically this is a very flexible
formulation in which I can put I can
incorporate prayer knowledge about
distributions over policies and about
value functions or even say that I'm
doing imitation learning I know
something about what the stationary
diffusion should look like that I can
put in to put this knowledge into my to
constrict okay so that's good enough for
my set of point formulation so now let's
solve it the equation the algorithm is
very simple so essentially the hours on
this so Casio Korean descent algorithm
but a promoter version using a
particular information projection in the
dual space so what's happening us I know
that my value function lies in our
infinity box so that part is easy but I
do know that I do variable is actually a
distribution so you order to learn a
distribution fast enough the natural
recommend divergence is cow divergence
okay and I'm using multiplicative
updates in a dual variable so what's
going on with our equation we can pick
one single state action and state
transition that's all the information we
need for one equation so we're going to
be sampling I a and the worst j.j that's
all we need and using ia and J we can
quickly calculate samples of the two
random variables in my updates and
actually both of them are vectors was
one or two entries well not only one or
two nonzero entries so it's really just
a stochastic when descent iteration with
particular construction
okay so this is what the algorithm looks
like so I just wanna say that the
algorithm is primal dual and it's also a
coordinated algorithm because we are
only updating a few coordinates at each
new iteration this makes a lot of sense
because we are only drawing a very small
piece of information one
state-transition Pro iteration so we are
really we are we only have a few bits
new a few new bits each sample and we
are only apply a few updates to a few
core swap your coordinates and also if
you look at this closely
so in sexually this mimics actually do
syntax matter in a way that we are
applying a soft P vote using multiple
updates rather than a hard people like
induce impacts okay so now let's prove
some without so by analyzing the
promoter convergence and the using
marking go concentration and further by
rounding the duality gap to error in the
policy and doing all the tricks we can
show that it's possible to find an
absolute optimal policy in this run time
and what's going on here is that so my
first term is a pre-processing time and
my second term actually comes from
running the algorithm and I have some
additional term due to policy evaluation
so the first convexity is a nearly
linear run ham complexity for sabe MPP
already faster one our requirement for
absolutist reasonably not super small
and furthermore if we look at this
convexity what we don't like is the
first term a square a so this is a
linear term this will be sub linear
right so however it's possible that we
can rid of this I square a as long as
the problem specifications are given in
nice data structures so because all I
need is to be able to generate samples
sample transition of the decision
process
so what I care about her can i generate
state transitions you know one time so
this is doable as long as we approve as
long as we're pre-process the data in a
way for example we can pre-process my
distribution vectors into a binary tree
so I can sample them using log and time
without be enough okay so after apply
all this techniques this is the final
result so we can get a sub linear
runtime complexity for approximating
solving average reward Markov decision
process and notice that we do have this
dependence on the range of station
distributions how and the mixing time of
the process and I'm I am not sure
whether this part is improvable or not
the good news is actually for
large-scale MVP this run time could be
even smaller than the size of the input
so we can approximately solve it without
reading odin input bits okay
so that's for the commutation problem
problem of AM boutique so I just want to
say a little bit that that the messer
are just described also applied to the
reinforcement learning setting because
it is naturally an algorithm that uses
sample transitions to make updates so
the difference between reinforcement
learning and Markov decision processes
are following so MVP will in the
computational world and we are given all
the numerical values of transition
probabilities and rewards so we all we
know all those values and now in the
world of reinforcement learning we only
have a simulator of the game in a sense
that we can only choose state and
actions and sometimes we cannot even
true state we can just play this game
and try different actions and observe
what happens on the path of the game so
this is the setting of reinforcement
learning again we want to solve the same
as magical problem but we can only
access information by playing this game
okay
oh by the way so popular methods in
green formal learning like cue learning
and temporal difference learning are
essentially randomized versions of
matter equation
well actor critic and policy gradient
are essentially randomized version of
policy equation and there are also many
other versions like a CCD shoe and they
are those algorithms together with deep
learning or some other Prometric
functions okay so let's continue with
the tabular case without any prima
transition so the high-level idea is to
apply this primal dual randomized
algorithm in a way so that I'm going to
play this game on a single game pass and
I'm going to make updates as long as I
observe a significant number of distinct
states and then I make the updates and
then I keep doing this
so there's hours on this model free
because we never have to estimate the
transition probabilities which are not
known we only need to update the value
estimate and the policy updates direct
the the policy as much directory okay so
in the setting of reinforcement learning
we care about us like in a slightly
different notion of complexity so
because now we are going to be playing
this game once but we are going to play
it on an infinite sample path so now I
care about how many mistakes the
algorithm is going to make before it
becomes accident optimal in all future
moves and that is called the sample
complexity of exploration and now due to
the dependency on a single sample path
we're going to add a little bit to the
strategy we add a factor of mixing time
and a square root factor of that
parameter however if we compare the
complexity of this primordial method was
delayed pure learning which is the only
some polka laxative extrusion for
q-learning
that I know about okay and we note that
this one is definitely better than later
learning for certain values absolute and
my work applies to the undiscounted case
so it's a little hard to compare the
dependence on other parameters okay so I
just want to say that by using this type
of przemo do matter with online learning
we can already achieve optimal sample
complexity in estimation in in the
dependence on state space dimension
actions face dimension and absolute and
also we can characterize how the mixing
time how slow the process is and also
the hot what is the range of the
decision process we can characterize how
those parameters change play a role in a
complexity of learning the optimal
policy and definitely I think what has
to be improved or to be better students
whether the assumptions are mixing
kindness to restrictive or not it's not
clear whether we're the lower bound lies
lies so for certain problems when the
process actually mixes rapidly I think
this algorithm is going to be pretty
efficient so we have a mixing process an
example be autonomous driving because
whenever we drive our car and we do
something wrong we're going to crash
immediately so a different a counter
example will be like if I search in a
maze I could be making a wrong move in
the beginning but it'd take me a super
long time to realize so those two type
of games are very different in terms of
how fast they mix under reasonable
policies okay
so okay so what I just described are how
to use the sampling mechanism to speed
up to speed up the computation of an
absolute optimal policy for Markov
decision process and what makes me very
curious was it looks like the data
structure of the problem actually
matters
what is that for the same problem
the runtime connected he is going to
reduce from linear to sub linear if the
data structures are good so I want to
explain why this matters and
I'm going to prove that the data
structure matters not only in the upper
bound for random complexity but also in
the lower bound for random complexity so
what's going on is this so the algorithm
is always going to be some ho
state prime condition of current state
and the current action so this is I in
critical step in the randomized
algorithm we are going to be simulating
the process and then we apply promoter
updates who learn it so in order to make
the algorithm run fast I want this step
to be done in Judah or one time so how
do I do this let me look at my vector of
transition probabilities for specific as
an a so say that this is my transition
probabilities
this is my Probie vector so if I want a
some hope from this probability vector
typically if I don't do anything the
time I need is going to be okay
so however if I transform it into a
cumulative distribution by simply doing
now if I want to generate state s
transpose state as prime according to
this cumulative distribution I can
simply generate a random variable
uniformly from 0 and 1 and then do a
binary search to locate the quiz
bounding interval and those can be done
in so this is a trivial without from
theory of computing so we can generate a
sample from a descriptive actor in
nearly constant time and for Markov
decision process our input happened to
be such discrete probability acres so we
want to pre-process them into cumulative
distributions or binary trees with some
other 19 structures
she'll generate a samples ok and now we
get nearly oh one run time for
generating each sample so this is
important in a way that it's draws a
strong connection between run time
complexity for solving the computation
problem and sample complexity for
learning the optimal policy so basically
as long as I get a nice learning
algorithm I should be able to adapt it
into a fast computation algorithm
because I can simulate the process super
fast ok
so however this phenomenon is curious so
why would data structures make the
problem different so that's motivating
need to look into lower bound of MVP so
when I want to understand how the lower
bound of random complexity of Markov
decision problems if
the data structures then I look into the
already twitchers Markov decision
problems and I barely found any lower
bound so I mean we lower so the closest
lower bound will be like poem VPS peace
based heart but that's not a youthful
lower bound in my situation and also
true on two tables they have some
information lower bound for smooth
hamilton-jacobi equations but in general
there's no computational capacity and
lower bound that helps me how many are
many equations I need to solve given
size problems I do know that there are
many sample complexity lower bounds in
the literature of reinforcement learning
but you all know that sample callosity
is different from commutation complexity
okay so that is our so we prove the
lower bounds so the lower bound this
okay the result reads very naively the
lower bound Vedas is that you have to
read most of entries in the data input
in order to find reasonable absolute
approximate policy in the case one my
mobility vectors are given in this form
just a discrete vector of abilities okay
so this lower bail is not surprising
although it's takes I don't know many
pages to prove but it's not surprising
at all okay so so it's actually good
because we have already shown that it's
possible to solve MTP in nearly in
nearly linear run time so the upper and
lower bound nearly match and second as
look at special cases when my data are
already pre processed into cumulative
distributions or binary trees so
actually we look at both cases and in
those two cases even the lower bound
changes so in those cases the lower
bound changes to as a over absolute time
some constant factor so this is quite
interesting so if we put together the
upper bounds in the case with standard
input and the cumulative disagree input
together with the two lower bounds in
the two different case of data
structures both them show that the
complexity of MVP actually depends on
data structures and once we can somehow
using the later data structure the
problem becomes simpler so it's a very
interesting phase transition and let me
explain what a lower bound means the
lower bound means that no matter you can
use any hours of any randomized
algorithm but however for any randomized
algorithm in order to get an absolute
optimal policy with a high probability
the algorithm needs at least there's
money curious from entries which is a
lower bound who run time complexity here
so they are actually lower bound for
adaptive curious eyes not sample
complexity so they are stronger okay
okay so that's the lower bound and my
last page is something I just want to
advocate for my collaborators so so so
baby there's a still a gap between upper
and lower bound so we try to code that
gap so when you actually we are working
on as we try to accelerate valuation
methods so we do know that value
iteration converges geometrically fast
but each situation is going to be
time-consuming due to calculating of all
the inner products so we want to use
learning an element randomization to
accelerate that part so we have choose
that without for discounted problems
okay so it's possible that we use
randomized evaluation to achieve again
sub linear runtime for solving this
County MVP and we have a discount factor
and this also occurs assumption that my
data is pretty processed in a way that I
can directly example I can't you okay
stimulate the decision process okay and
alternatively if we do now like this
absolute square dependence alternatively
we can spend more time
our pre-processing to get a high
accuracy absolute optimal solution the
alternative solution is we can get a
logarithm log 1 over absolute dependence
by doing a pre-processing every few
iterations so this is a joint work was
Aaron stood for Karen whoo where's
Carrie
it carries here and India ok and we are
trying to push the limit and see whether
we can close this gap so a short summary
is it is really curious that run time
complexity of MVP actually depends on
the data structures and as you can see
that once we can somehow then we can do
a lot of those learning tricks so I
shouldn't say approximately eco but I
think sample complexity is definitely
strongly related to run time complexity
for MVP
and that also means that three informal
learning at America of the same process
they are similar problems we want to
look at them together okay and also we
know that there's definitely still a gap
between the upper and lower bound we
have a gap we means one factor of
Epsilon and also dependence on discount
factor mixing time and range of recorded
distributions although dependents are
not clear yet so that's the open
question we have thank you very much
[Applause]
so you mentioned trust adults were
depending on the mixing language so
these new results don't depend on mixing
time anymore so that without applies to
the undiscounted problem so without any
discount factor problem is essentially
unbounded so I assume the mixing hime
and our God is a tea for example if we
consider a problem which could be mixing
super slow so within a maybe mixing time
is I don't know several orders of the
dimension of the input so I have to
really wait for a super long time before
I observe anything useful so that would
be a case in which the mixing time
really kills the problem but in a
discounted case once we have a discount
factor it means that when I look into
the future and from certain time on Oh
futures are going to be claiming such as
mojo so I can ignore them so basically
discount factor or mixing time both of
them are playing some cap on the time
dependency of the Pro of the process you
might hope
yeah I think it's definitely I mean I
wouldn't say definitely okay I would say
that in the case when we have to rely on
samples that dependence is actually
optimal I can prove our Cybercom has a
lower bound but in the case when we know
all the input as possible to improve
their dependence that dependence is not
good enough
so usually the transitions between
spades states is sparse so do like
valence that depend on the sparsity of
the transition matrix I do not but I I
will say that so essentially the current
upper bounds are essentially linear with
respect to the number of state action
pairs but however the sparsity of
transition would help in this part in
those hours in which we have to
pre-process then we should be able to
replace this quantity with the number of
non-zeros and that would make this
complexity Martian eyes are looking
thank you
[Applause]